so now comes the leader of the
opposition kill Starbuck
thank you Mr Speaker Last Summer the
Prime Minister claimed he wanted to
protect free speech and put a stop to no
platforming so how concerned was he by
last week's campaign by Tory MPS to
cancel a broadcaster
Mr
Mr Speaker as I said as I said at the
time the issues between Gary lineker and
the BBC were for them to resolve and I'm
very glad I'm very I'm very glad that
they did and we're looking forward to
watching match of the day again on our
screensaver Mr Mr Speaker the sight of
them howling with rage over a tweet
signing greeting letters in their dozens
desperately trying to cancel a football
highlight show that should have been
laughable instead it led to a farcical
weekend with the national broadcast
being accused of dancing to the
government's tune by its own employees
rather than blame everyone else why
doesn't it take some responsibility
stand up to his snowflake MPS Waging War
on Free Speech
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I Mr Speaker just the usual
usual political opportunism
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't I don't know if he noticed I
don't know if he knows this but actually
first the shadow attorney general and
then the shadow Home Secretary actually
criticized the language that had been
used in the tree
political bandwagon and changed his mind
First Armor so Mr Speaker
July
I'm not being funny I think our
constituents something to get to the
budget the more that you showed the more
you progressed questions so please my
constituents interested if yours are
gizama Mr Speaker they want more of a
prime minister who doesn't understand
you can disagree with what somebody says
but still defend their right to say it
we're in a real problem does he accept
that people's concerns about the BBC
have been made worse because the
government chose to put a Tory donor
with no broadcasting experience in
charge of the BBC
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you chairman
[Applause]
he was appointed
he was he was appointed
at the same applies to this side this
budget matters to the people of this
country they won't hear it don't keep
questions going longer than need me
prime minister
dependent and long-established process
ported by expert panel members as well
as the cross as well as the cross party
dcms select committee now that is right
that process that process is being that
process is being independently reviewed
by the office for commissioner of public
appointments and we should allow that
review to conclude
the problem is the chair of the BBC
isn't just any old Tory donor
it's so close to the Prime Minister
audit this
I want you to be
to budget cup of Tea's don't want to
come that early Mr Speaker he's no
ordinary Tori donut he's so close to the
Prime Minister he's been described as
his mentor he helped arrange an 800 000
pound credit line for the former prime
minister a minor detail he forgot to
tell the select committee which
scrutinized his appointment does the
Prime Minister think that his friend's
position is still tenable
well Mr Speaker as I've just said
the office for in the independent office
for commissioner of public appointments
is reviewing what was a rigorous
independent process to appoint the
chairman instead of pre-judging and
preempting that review we should let it
conclude and wait for the outcome that
is the right way to do things and that's
what the government will do
Mr Speaker when people with links to the
Tory party somehow find themselves in
senior positions at the BBC it's
important that their impartiality is
seen to be Beyond reproach so has the
promise to received assurances but no
one with links to the Tory party was
lobbied by Tory MPS or involved in the
decision that saw match of the day
effectively canceled
Mr Speaker these as I said these These
are matters these are matters for the
BBC to resolve and it's right it's right
that the BBC as an important institution
takes its obligations to impartiality
seriously right I I care about the
integrity and partiality of Institutions
the BBC but also the Civil Service Mr
Speaker and it's right that those
processes carry on properly but what I
would say to him what I would say to him
on this matter there is an independent
review it's right that that process
concludes and he would I would hope
respect that process
[Applause]
he comes here today with his Minnie
Mouse platitudes pretending the actions
of his party have nothing to do with him
but the whole country saw how he kept
quiet and hid behind the playground
bullies while they try to drive someone
out Simply for disagreeing with them an
impartial public broadcaster free of
government interference is a crucial
pillar in our country but isn't that put
at risk by the council culture addicts
on his benches for BBC
internet demands and a prime minister
too weak to do anything about them
Mr Speaker we're not going to take any
lectures on cancer culture from the
party officer
he's avoided it in six questions the
actual the substance of the issue that
this underlied this tweet and that's
what has he done in this past week the
only thing he and his party have done is
voted against our bill to stop the boats
Mr Speaker siding with people Smugglers
over the British people that's
what's happened instead what have we
done is conclude a new migration deal
with France Mr Speaker we've managed to
sign a new defense partnership with our
allies the US and Australia we've
protected British startups and we have
boosted defense spending and that Mr
Speaker is what delivering for Britain
looks like
foreign